Das ist etwas, wo ich mir wirklich
wünschen würde, dass all die Autofans,
die jahrzehntelang ihre Partys hatten,
dass sie jetzt endlich mal auch verstehen,
wir leben im 21. Jahrhundert: Dinge
müssen wir verändern, sonst geht es auf so vielen
Ebenen und nicht nur dem Klimaschutz
nicht weiter.
Wir starten direkt mit der ersten
Frage von 13 Fragen, mit der Konflikt Frage:
Müssen Innenstädte autofrei werden
oder zumindest weitestgehend autofrei werden?
Wenn ihr sagt: "Ja, auf jeden Fall"
dann geht ihr jetzt bitte aufs grüne Feld.
Und wenn ihr sagt: "Nein, auf gar
keinen Fall" dann geht jetzt bitte aufs gelbe
Feld. Jeder Haushalt besitzt
durchschnittlich mehr als ein Auto
in Deutschland, die Zahl der zugelassenen
PKW ist im letzten Jahr sogar gestiegen
und das, obwohl wir gerade jetzt
eigentlich alles dafür tun sollten,
CO2 einzusparen. Und das Klima
ist ja nur die eine Sache. Staus,
vollgepackte Innenstädte, Unfälle all
das könnte durch weniger Autoverkehr reduziert
werden. Sprich mehr Lebensqualität
für alle. Das sagt zumindest die eine Seite,
die andere Seite ist sich sicher, Autos
verbieten, das ist komplett realitätsfern,
das schadet der Wirtschaft, schränkt
die Freiheitsrechte ein und es diskriminiert
auch noch genau diejenigen, die auf ihr Auto
angewiesen sind. Ihr merkt,
die Fronten sind verhärtet. Aber
ich bin eigentlich ganz optimistisch,
dass wir heute den einen oder anderen
Kompromiss finden oder ja,
vielleicht sogar eine Lösung, wie wir in Zukunft
Mobilität für uns alle, aber eben
auch fürs Klima besser gestalten
können. Aber jetzt erst mal die Frage an euch:
Wo auf dem Feld würdet ihr stehen?
Grün oder gelb? Schreibt es mir gerne
in die Kommentare. Dann gilt
für euch, liebe Gäste, ab jetzt,
wenn ihr der anderen Seite in einem
Argument, in einem Punkt was auch immer
zustimmt, dann könnt ihr gerne
einen Schritt nach vorne gehen.
Und wenn ihr der anderen Seite
überhaupt nicht zustimmt, auch während die andere
Person redet und ihr möchte das unbedingt
zum Ausdruck bringen, dann geht ihr einen
Schritt zurück ins hintere Feld.
Meint Ziel ist natürlich heute so viele
wie möglich von euch hier im Kompromissfeld
zu sehen, mal gucken,
ob das gelingt. Ich beginne jetzt mit dir
Sophia. Du hast einen Instagram Account,
der voll von Fotos und Videos von dir
mit Autos ist. Man merkt, Autos sind
deine absolute Leidenschaft, du
liebst das über alles. Warum Wurde mir so
in die Wiege gelegt einfach. Und spätestens
mit meinem Führerschein dann
war für mich klar, Autos werden
später mein Leben erfüllen. Allerdings werde
ich heute mal meine Leidenschaft außen
vor lassen, sondern tatsächlich mal das große
Ganze betrachten und wirklich
auch mit einbeziehen, was vielleicht
für die meisten Menschen am sinnvollsten
wäre. Und wie oft nutzt du dein Auto?
Täglich täglich? Innenstädte
autofrei zu bekommen klingt für mich absolut
unrealistisch. Ich liebe mein Auto
und viele Leute sind einfach auf ihr Auto
angewiesen und werden es auch weiterhin
immer sein. Es bietet uns Freiheit
und für mich ist es auch nicht der Klimasünder
Nummer eins auf dieser Welt.
Nina, wenn es nach dir geht, dann
hätte Sophia für das ganze Jahr nur noch 12
Fahrten übrig, die sie überhaupt
fahren könnte. Warum? Genau. Also ich denke,
dass die meisten Autofahrten nicht
unbedingt nötig sind, nicht unbedingt
sinnvoll sind, weil meistens nur eine Person
transportiert wird. Und ich glaube
einfach, wir sollten wenn dann Autos
nur für weite Fahrten oder für Urlaubsfahrten
für Transporte nutzen, aber nicht im Alltag,
weil das einfach ungerechtfertigt
ist, so viel Energie auf zu brauchen
für eine Einzelperson, die von A nach B fährt.
Wir wollen mit der Initiative "Berlin
autofrei" allen Berliner*innen eine Stimme
geben, die sich für die Verkehrswende
einsetzen wollen. Wir wollen klar machen,
dass das Auto in der Stadt viel zu viel
Platz einnimmt, dass wir den Raum uns
zurückholen müssen und wollen
einfach zeigen, wie eine lebenswerte Stadt
der Zukunft aussehen kann. Und dazu
gehören eben keine Autos. Das bedeutet
also, die Autos sollen jetzt gar
nicht unbedingt verschwinden und jeder soll
sie abschaffen oder verkaufen, sondern sie sollen
raus aus der Innenstadt, oder?
Wie genau kann man sich das vorstellen?
Genau. Ich bin jetzt nicht gegen Autos
per se, aber gerade in der Innenstadt
ist der öffentliche Raum einfach ein unfassbar
wertvolles Gut. Und den können wir nicht
voll stellen mit Autos. Das ist einfach
überhaupt nicht verhältnismäßig,
gerade in Innenstädten. Und genauso wenig ist
es verhältnismäßig, wenn man
sich überlegt, was für ein hohes
Sicherheitsrisiko die Autos ausmachen,
wie viel Emissionen sie haben. Es gibt einfach
tausend Gründe, die gegen einen
Auto sprechen, gerade in der Innenstadt.
Auf dem Land, finde ich, sieht das nochmal
anders aus. Auch da wäre es schön,
wenn nicht alle aufs Auto angewiesen
sind, aber gerade in der Innenstadt ist
es überhaupt nicht
verhältnismäßig. Alicia, was hältst du von Ninas Idee?
Nur noch zwei Fahrten pro Jahr macht
mich traurig ehrlicherweise. Und ich finde,
es schränkt auch einfach ein.
In der persönlichen Freiheit, also
an der aktuellen Debatte rund ums
Auto, ärgert mich einfach, dass die Autos so
wahnsinnig böse angesehen werden.
Und auch: Je größer die Autos, je größer
die Motoren, desto böser sind die Menschen,
die da drin sitzen. Es werden
immer mehr Fahrradwege gebaut, die zweispurigen
Straßen werden auf einspurig
runtergesetzt. In dem Moment haben
wir Stau. Also Autofahren wird regelrecht
madig gemacht. Die Frage, die mir
jetzt gerade kam, ist: Wenn wir zwölf Fahrten
haben, wo steht dann das Auto, wenn wir es nicht
nutzen? Also wir können ja nicht
irgendwie zwölf Fahrten machen,
einmal im Monat und den Rest, dann steht es ja
auch rum und wahrscheinlich steht
es dann auch in der Innenstadt rum. Genau
deswegen ist es ja auch sinnvoll, wenn wir nicht
alle ein eigenes Auto besitzen,
weil das Auto auch jetzt gerade
schon 23 Stunden am Tag einfach nur rumsteht.
Insofern denke ich, ist es viel
sinnvoller, da auf Sharing-Varianten
überzugehen und zu schauen, Okay,
wie können wir die Autos, die wir wirklich
brauchen, maximal in Bewegung halten,
damit sie uns eben nicht den öffentlichen
Raum wegnehmen? Katja Alicia
macht den Vorschlag traurig. Macht er dich
-auch traurig? Stimmt ihr da zu?
-Ich glaube, Mobilität ist halt etwas, wo
wir immer erst auf uns gucken und gucken:
Wie geht es uns mit der Mobilität,
die wir gerade haben? Und leider
ist die Klimakrise die uns anfeuert aber
eigentlich auch ein Gerechtigkeits
Thema. Und deswegen kann ich durchaus "traurig"
verstehen, weil es natürlich auch um die eigene
persönliche Mobilität geht, aber
es geht ja auch immer um andere,
die wir einschränken durch das Auto.
Also tatsächlich habe ich das Gefühl,
dass es jetzt einfach mal an der Zeit ist,
alle anderen, die vielleicht kein
Auto haben oder es sich nicht leisten können,
mal in den Vordergrund rücken und ich glaube,
bei Städten vor dem Auto hatten
wir das ja. Wir hatten
Begegnungszonen, wir konnten einander begegnen,
ohne dass man Gefahr lief, irgendwie
verletzt zu werden. Und das heißt nicht,
dass die Autos alle Privilegien
verlieren, aber auf jeden Fall teilen müssen. Also,
es muss genauso unbequem sein, Auto
zu fahren, wie zum Beispiel zuFuß zu gehen.
Simon, du bist Sprecher des Verbands
der Automobilindustrie. Das heißt, du hast
tagtäglich mit dem Thema Mobilität zu tun.
Warum brauchen wir denn deiner Meinung
nach keine autofreien Innenstädte, um Klima
und Lebensqualität, was gerade schon
-angesprochen wurde, zu verbessern?
-Also ich glaube, in dem Ziel sind wir uns
einig: Klima verbessern,
Lebensqualität verbessern. Das sehe ich ganz genauso.
Ich glaube immer nur, dass Verbote
der falsche Weg sind. Es gibt Menschen,
die sind weiterhin auf das Auto
angewiesen: Pendler, Familien mit Kindern,
Menschen in Schichtarbeit. All diese Menschen
können ohne Auto teilweise gar
nicht ihren Job und ihr Leben
verwirklichen. In Deutschland arbeiten
über 800000 Menschen in der Automobilindustrie.
Fast zwei Millionen
Arbeitsplätze hängen indirekt
an der Autoindustrie. Und bei allen
Entscheidungen, die wir treffen,
müssen wir immer daran denken,
wie wir auch deren Lebensrealitäten
berücksichtigen können. Und da gibt es ja
Lösungen. Man kann ja durchaus auch den Verkehrsfluss
und auch den ruhenden
Verkehr in der Stadt
runterfahren. Es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten,
die in der Digitalisierung liegen.
Wurde ja immer schon mal angesprochen: Shared
Services, Pool-Riding, all das,
das sollte man ja auch nutzen, da sind
wir auch dafür. Aber grundsätzlich
gesehen sollte man immer eher auf Innovationen
-setzen statt auf Verbote.
-Du bist einen Schritt zurückgegangen und
-verlässt gleich das Studio.
-Tatsächlich geht es mir nicht darum
Verbote - fahr mal als radfahrende
Person, zu Fuß gehende Person, als jemand
im Rollstuhl durch Berlin Hamburg
oder jede Stadt. Du hast so viele Verbote,
bei denen Autos einfach
unausgesprochen Rechte gegeben werden. Ich fühle mich
nicht gleichberechtigt, wenn ich Rad
fahre in Hamburg, sondern ich fühle mich
als eine Person, die immer auf sich
aufpassen muss. Also Verbote sind
unausgesprochen für Menschen
ohne Auto schon längst da.
Also ich fahre auch Fahrrad in Berlin.
Natürlich kann man da- Also ich finde
auch, dass man da was tun kann
dafür, dass es vielleicht mehr Radwege gibt.
Da spricht ja gar nichts dagegen.
Aber ich glaube, grundsätzlich gesehen ist
dieses ganze gegeneinander ausspielen
"nicht Auto, sondern Fahrrad" der komplett
falsche Weg. Es ist doch sowohl Auto,
als auch Fahrrad als auch Scooter,
als auch zu Fuß, alles
nebeneinander. Also ich verstehe gar nicht, warum man
-das gegeneinander ausspielt.
-Sophia, du bist ein Schritt
zurückgegangen. Warum? Auf das Argument
wollte ich grade mal eingehen, bezüglich,
dass man als Fahrradfahrer
eigentlich benachteiligt ist. Also es werden
in den Städten immer mehr
Fahrradwege gebaut. Es gibt in vielen,
vielen Großstädten mittlerweile auch schon
Gebiete, wo ja Straßen gesperrt sind
für Autos, zum Beispiel Hamburg. Ich weiß
nicht Jungfernstieg zum Beispiel ist jetzt
auch so ein Thema. Und diese Straße,
die oder die Innenstädte leiden ja
auch darunter, weil eben auch nicht
mehr dieser Spontanität da ist, dass man sich
in sein Auto setzt und mal eben
irgendwo in die Stadt fährt zum Einkaufen.
Das heißt, die ganzen Läden, die jetzt
schon eher darunter leiden, dass es immer
mehr Online-Shops gibt und dass man
immer mehr online bestellen kann, werden früher
oder später noch mehr darunter leiden,
wenn es eben nicht mehr diese Spontanität
gibt für die Menschen, einfach so in die Stadt
zu fahren. Ganz kurz einmal ans
grüne Feld. Ihr könnt auch einfach
am Rande des Feldes sein, weil sonst seid
ihr nachher aus dem Studio raus, das wäre
ein bisschen schade. Raul, warum man sich
-gerade nach hinten bewegt?
-Ich finde diese Debatten unglaublich
anstrengend, weil es eigentlich
nichts anderes ist als Whataboutism. Und das,
was unserer Seite ja die ganze Zeit
vorgeworfen wird, als die Leute, die sagen
"wir wollen, dass es weniger Fahrzeuge
in der Innenstadt gibt" ist das uns ständig
gesagt wird "Naja, ihr wollt irgendwie
die Leute gegeneinander ausspielen." Aber
wir wurden ja jahrzehntelang gegen Autofahrer*innen
ausgespielt. Und jetzt
benutzt ihr unsere Argumente,
nämlich, dass die Krankenschwester
oder irgendjemand mit der Mobilität
ja sonst eingeschränkt ist, wenn wir Autos
verbieten. Diejenigen, die strikt
gegen autofreie Städte sind, würde ich einfach
erst mal sagen: Checkt mal eure Privilegien!
Warum seid ihr dagegen?
Ist es einfach nur, dass sie keine
Lust hat, eure Komfortzone zu verlassen?
Oder habt ihr wirklich triftige
Gründe? Und wenn es euch wirklich darum geht,
mega schnell durch die Stadt zu rasen,
dann geht an den Nürnburgring und macht
was ihr dort wollt und was man da darf.
Aber bitte verpestet damit nicht
unsere Innenstädte. Wann hat sich
eigentlich der VDA und alle Autofans
jemals dafür eingesetzt, dass der ÖPNV
ausgebaut wird? Wann ist das eigentlich
jemals geschehen? Seit Jahrzehnten
passiert da relativ wenig und wir stellen
uns oft dann eben auf die Frage: Warum wird
aus einem BMW Mini ein Auto, dass so
groß ist wie ein Jeep. Wann ist
das eigentlich passiert? Warum wurden
wir nicht gefragt, ob das cool ist,
dass ein Auto, das ein Parkplatz braucht,
plötzlich zwei braucht? Und das gleiche
Fahrzeug- Die Fahrzeuge sind ja nicht
besser geworden. Du kommst mit Whataboutism
- Sondern sie nehmen Menschen
wie mir Mobilität, weil wenn ich die Straße
überqueren möchte, dann nicht mehr
gesehen werde, weil ich einfach so
klein bin im Verhältnis zu so einem Panzer,
dass die Gefahr für mich auf jeden
Fall steigt überfahren zu werden.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht persönlich
beurteilen. Was ich aber sagen kann ist,
die Größe von Autos ist noch mal ein ganz
anderes Thema, wo wir bei Whataboutism
waren und jetzt erst bei den Innenstadtproblem
und Größen von Autos.
Man muss das schon noch alles ein wenig
unterscheiden. Es gibt auch viele kleine
Modelle, die neu rausgekommen sind
und wenn es um den Ausbau von ÖPNV geht,
also da kann man alle
Positionen nachlesen. Wir sind absolut dafür,
dass der ÖPNV ausgebaut wird. Ich habe
ja jetzt auch in jeder meiner Aussagen klar
gemacht: Alternativen schaffen, dann
kann man darüber diskutieren, welche Lösung
-es gibt.
-Aber im Moment bestimmt ja im Moment
bestimmt ja ihr, wann wir darüber
reden dürfen-
Darf ich einmal bitte ausreden, weil ich gerne
das Argument zu Ende bringen würde.
Ich glaube, genau das passiert eben
nicht. Zum Beispiel die Bahn hat ihr Verkehrsnetz
in den letzten Jahrzehnten um 30
Prozent zurückgebaut. Also es ist ja nicht so,
dass die Menschen wirklich in dem Maße
mobil sein können aktuell,
wie sie es sein müssten. Und ich finde
tatsächlich, dass Mobilität ein Grundrecht
ist. Mobilität ist das Instrument
um Teilhabe am gesellschaftlichen Leben,
am Arbeitsleben [zu ermöglichen].
Und das müssen wir allen ermöglichen
und wir müssen gemeinsame Lösungen
finden. Also ich gerade was den ruhenden Verkehr
angeht, bin ich komplett bei dir. Also
man kann Systeme finden. Es gibt mittlerweile
zum Beispiel, wiedermal
Digitalisierung, Autos, die sich gegenseitig über freie
Parkplätze informieren und dadurch
wird zum Beispiel dieser ganze Verkehr
reduziert. Oder dass man
beispielsweise sagt: "Okay, wir machen mehr
in Parkhäusern." Ja, zum Beispiel
könnte man sagen: "Okay, wenn wir es erleichtern,
die Zufahrten zu Parkhäusern, dafür
können wir vielleicht sogar bestimmte Straßen
verkehrsberuhigend machen. Aber
die Zufahrten zu den Parkhäusern müssen
in einem Zustand sein, so
würde man ruhenden Verkehr reduzieren.
Raul, du sagst Innovationen wie zum Beispiel
Carsharing und so weiter –das
Wort Innovation ist ja jetzt schon
sehr, sehr viel gefallen– oder auch E-Autos sind
schön und gut, die bringen ja aber
in der Regel überhaupt gar nichts. Warum?
Das fängt alleine schon damit an,
dass eine Stadt wie Hannover oder Hamburg,
so Sharing Anbieter bzw.
Ride-Hailing Anbieter wie Moia – die so eine Art
Alternative oder ein komplett privates
ÖPNV darstellen sollen– dass kein einziges
von deren Fahrzeugen für Menschen,
die im Rollstuhl sitzen, zugänglich ist.
Und es wird damit argumentiert, dass das nicht
geht, weil sie elektrisch sind
und dadurch letztendlich die Sitzhöhe
höher ist und eine Rampe
in diese Fahrzeuge nicht
einzubauen ist. Und ich stelle mir die Frage,
wie eine Stadt wie Hamburg
oder Hannover das zulassen konnte,
wenn es als Innovation gefeiert wird,
aber gleichzeitig behinderte Menschen ganz
bewusst dann auch ausschließt und hinzu
kommt auch die Frage: Es gibt bisher kein
einziges Fahrzeug, das elektrisch
ist, dass Menschen, die auf den Rollstuhl
angewiesen sind, überhaupt benutzen
können. Und jede Ladesäule, die momentan
in Berlin oder in Deutschland
installiert wird, ist für Menschen, die im Rollstuhl
sitzen, nicht zugänglich, weil die Steckdosen
zu hoch sind. Und wir bauen
diese Dinger gerade zu Tausenden
aus. Und die hätten es so leicht gehabt,
das von Anfang an mitzudenken. Aber
es wird nicht getan, weil auch hier wieder
eine gesetzliche Regulierung fehlt
und eine Verpflichtung. Und dieses Argument,
dass ich dann oft aus der Seiten
der Privatwirtschaft höre "Ja, wir müssen
das auf Freiwilligkeit machen, wir sind
ja alle für alles." Aber wenn es nicht
reguliert ist, dann passiert es nicht.
Genauso wie die Gleichberechtigung
zwischen Mann und Frau in der Automobilindustrie
offensichtlich nicht
freiwillig geschehen ist. In Führungsetagen
muss das reguliert werden!
Genau das gleiche mit CO2-Reduktion.
Es musste reguliert werden. Es geht nicht
freiwillig An das gelbe Feld: Ihr könnt
euch gerne positionieren, einen Schritt
auf Raul zugehen, wenn er euch dazu
bewegt hat. Also ich denke, dass in der Zukunft,
je mehr E-Autos es geben wird und je mehr
der Ausbau von Ladesäulen stattfinden
wird, gerade auch, da vielleicht
auf den behinderten Parkplätzen viel mehr
auf das Thema eingegangen wird.
Das ist - Ich kann das - Ich habe keine
Berührungspunkte damit.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch keinen Schritt
nach vor oder zurück gegangen, weil ich das nicht
einschätzen kann. Aber du kannst
es jetzt mit seiner
persönlichen Einschätzung vielleicht besser
-einschätzen. Ihr könnt euch ja zuhören.
-Du kannst ja nicht die ganze Zeit über
-Mobilität reden und Inklusion rausnehmen.
-Behindertengerechten Parkplätzen oder auch
zum Beispiel also gerade was laden
angeht oder auch Carsharing angeht, da bin
ich seiner Meinung. Also da würde ich den Schritt
entgegenkommen. Nur finde ich,
das spielt ja gerade nicht so richtig
zum Thema, ob Städte autofrei werden sollen.
Katja, warum ist es dann eben doch
wichtig, wenn wir über eine autofreie
Stadt/Innenstadt sprechen, ja oder nein?
Auch diese ganze Diversität und Inklusion
-Themen mitzudenken?
-Also wer sich das noch aktuelle, also ich
glaube, er ist mittlerweile in Ehren
entlassen worden, Herr Scheuer.
Wenn wir uns das Ministerium zum Beispiel
angucken, da sind in den ersten drei
Etagen keine Frauen zu finden und die Männer,
die dort tätig sind, sind einander
sehr ähnlich. Und ich glaube, wenn ich mit 14
Katjas am Tisch sitzt und ich habe
eine super Idee, dann sagen alle 13
Katjas find ich auch gut, gut, gut. Die kommen
raus aus diesem Raum, sind sich
einig und haben aber Menschen vergessen,
weil sie nicht am Tisch sitzen. Die ganzen
Autogipfel, die es seit 2011 gibt,
waren nur Autogipfel. Es ging nur um ein Transportmittel.
Es waren keine Umwelt
Initiativen dabei, es waren keine
NGOs dabei, es war kein ÖPNV an Bord
und das sind Sachen. Das kann ich auch gar
nicht als Vorwurf platzieren,
weil wenn eine homogene Gruppe über
ein Problem spricht, dann ist sie sich einig,
hat aber Menschen vergessen, deren Stimme
wir brauchen. Und ich habe noch nie
gehört, dass wenn wir uns um Minderheiten
kümmern, der Mehrheit etwas geschadet
wird, sondern im Gegenteil. Meistens
ist es sogar so, dass zum Beispiel Sitzbänke
an Haltestellen, hochschwangere
Frauen, Menschen, die nicht mehr so gut gehen
können oder auch Kinder, die haben ja
alle was davon. Und ich glaube, diese Inklusion
heißt auch diesen Fokus mal ein bisschen
aufmachen und auf die Bedürfnisse
-zu schauen, nicht aufs Transportmittel.
-Also um auf die Bedürfnisse aller eingehen
zu können, finde ich es da der öffentliche
Verkehr eigentlich der falsche Weg.
Natürlich, wenn wir erst nächstes
Jahr mehr Gelder gegeben. Ich wollte dir
das nur erklären den Hintergrund. Ja,
Moment kurz. Einer meiner besten Freunde
ist zum Beispiel Rollstuhlfahrer. Und der,
der ist auch im Rennsport unterwegs.
Und ich kann mir im Leben nicht
vorstellen, auch er kann sich im Leben
nicht vorstellen, wie er, der reist
auch sehr viel beruflich durch seinein
Rennsport, mit öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln im Stadtverkehr unterwegs
sein soll. Klar, kann man das mehr
ausbauen, aber dennoch wird es trotzdem
immer noch gewisse Gruppen
einschränken, genauso wie Familien mit Kindern.
Wenn ich mir vorstellen würde, ich hätte
zwei, drei kleine Kinder und müsste immer
mit Öffis fahren und das eine Kind
muss dorthin, das andere Kind muss dahin.
Das ist so was aktuell zumindest
noch einschränkend für solche Gruppen.
Und zum Beispiel, ich könnte mir
auch nicht vorstellen, dass mein über
80-jähriger Opa mit dem Carsharing in der Innenstadt
irgendwo, der kann nicht mal
mit dem Handy klarkommen. Also an diese Leute
muss man ja auch mitdenken
und da kann man auch nicht sagen: Na
gut, dann müssen sie das lernen. Mein Opa,
der wäre aufgeschmissen, wenn er nicht
mehr mit seinem Auto unterwegs
sein könnte. Also du hast
dich nach vorne bewegt, ganz kurz.
Ich hab mich einen Schritt nach vorne
bewegt, weil ich dir zustimme,
dass wir natürlich alle Menschen
mitdenken sollten. Fakt ist aber auch meiner Ansicht
nach, dass ganz viele
Menschen bisher nicht mit bedacht wurden.
Und dass sie auch unterscheiden
müssen zwischen Verlassen der eigenen
Komfortzone. Also inwieweit ist
Autofahren für uns Hobby und inwieweit ist Autofahren
für uns aber auch wirklich
eine alternativlose Notwendigkeit?
Und bei der Frage wurden Menschen
mit Behinderung zum Beispiel meistens
-vergessen.
-Ja, das was du gerade ausgeführt hast,
dass 50 Prozent aller prekär
verdienenden Menschen haben keinen Führerschein
und kein Auto. Und denen sagen wir jetzt:
Ja, sorry Pech gehabt, die persönliche
Freiheit ist hier erstmal wichtiger.
Wir brauchen dies Ausbau, aus Klimagründen
und aus der sozialen Gerechtigkeit
heraus, weil die Menschen gerade skizziert hast.
Eine Frau und alleinerziehende
ohne Führerschein, ohne Möglichkeit Auto
zu fahren, mit Kindern. Was bieten wir ihr als Deutschland,
als hoch entwickeltes
Land? Wir nehmen einfach hin, dass wir solche
Leute nicht mitdenken und sagen
alle, die im Auto sitzen, machen das,
wir müssen das weiterführen. Nein, wir müssen
anders denken. Wir müssen gucken, was ist
mit solchen Menschen, die nicht viel
verdienen. Für die haben wir auf den Balkonen
geklatscht. Toll. Und jetzt
auf einmal sagen wir nee, wir machen
das weiter wie bisher und schließen
sie weiterhin aus.
Und da wehre ich mich gegen.
Aber das spielt Argumente
gegeneinander aus, die eigentlich in die gleiche
Richtung gehen. Das verstehe ich nicht,
weil wir alle sagen: Okay, es gibt
Menschen mit unterschiedlichsten
Lebensrealitäten, Lebenswirklichkeiten,
ob jetzt mit Auto oder ohne Auto,
ob Gutverdiener oder Schlechtverdiener.
Grundsätzlich haben wir doch alle
gesagt Mobilität ist etwas, was wir alle
brauchen, was wir im Täglichen um zur Arbeit
zu kommen, um am Kulturleben
teilzuhaben. Das ist ja außer
Frage. Glaubst du dass alle Mobilät haben
aktuell? Ich bin noch nicht fertig.
Also Mobilität allen Menschen ermöglichen. So,
und natürlich kann man jetzt immer
ein Beispiel rauspicken, wo was nicht
funktioniert. Fakt ist aber, dass die aktuelle
Situation in Städten nicht
hergibt, dass man die Autos quasi
sagt, wir machen jetzt autofreie Innenstädte.
Weil man dann damit bestimmten
Menschen das Leben erschweren würde,
weil die Alternativen doch noch gar
nicht da sind. Und man muss doch die Dinge
auch zu Ende denken. Und das geht
halt schon in so eine Richtung, wo ich sage,
das ist weit weg von der Lebensrealität
von manchen Menschen. Vielleicht nicht
in der Stadt, aber spätestens
dann, wenn wir auf dem Land sind, würde man
diesen Menschen wirklich einfach
sagen okay, Teilhabe ist halt nicht für jeden
zugänglich. Also wenn du uns
vorwirfst, wir würde das Thema derailen
oder auf andere Themen kommen.
Wir reden ja nur von Innenstädten.
Aber es gibt da viele Leute vom Land,
die in die Innenstädte müssen, um zu arbeiten.
-Ja, oder auch anders herum.
-Und da können wir natürlich ganz oft auch
sehen, wie schlecht eigentlich
der ÖPNV zwischen Stadt und Land ist
und wie der auch radikal reduziert
wurde in den letzten Jahren. Also da bin
ich voll auf eurer Seite. Die Frage,
die ich mir die ganze Zeit stelle, müssen
wir vielleicht noch unterscheiden
zwischen Hobby Autofahren machen macht mir Spaß.
Na, ja wenn ich aus Hobby Gründen
Auto fahre dann fahre ich auf der Rennstrecke
und das ist nicht in der Innenstadt.
Aber es gibt total viele Dudes. Ja, gibt
es natürlich. Alicia ganz kurz,
würdest du auf dein Hobby verzichten? Na ja,
ich meine, das ist genau wie Sophia
gesagt hat. Wenn wir schnell irgendwo fahren
wollen, dann fahren wir auf die Rennstrecke.
Aber in meinem normalen
persönlichen Leben gibt es keine
Hobby-Fahrten. Sondern, da wo ich hinfahre
fahr ich aus einem guten Grund, weil ich was besorgen
muss, was abholen muss.
Keine Ahnung, weil ich irgendwo ein Termin
habe oder so. Also Hobbys-Fahrten,
wo ich mich ins Auto setzen und sage
Ich mache jetzt mal coole Musik an und fahr
mal eine halbe Stunde rum, weil mir
langweilig ist. Sorry, aber sowas mache
-ich nicht, dafür habe ich gar keine Zeit.
-Woher denkst du, dann kommt die Statistik,
dass ein Auto nur 45 Minuten fährt
am Tag durchschnittlich mit 1,3 Personen?
Sind alle so wie du? Oder sind da vielleicht
doch ein paar Leute dabei,
die sogar 500 Meter zum Briefkasten
mit dem Auto fahren?
Es gibt wahrscheinlich Leute,
die 500 Meter zum Briefkasten fahren,
weil sie es einfach nicht mehr
laufen können, weil sie vielleicht COPD haben,
aus der Puste sind, was auch immer.
Aber auch diese im Supermarkt werden ja
auch mit dem ÖPNV möglich? Manche
Leute sagen, ich gehe einmal die Woche
oder einmal am Tag einkaufen und ich kaufe
nur ein Brot, eine Gurke und ein Saft.
Und die anderen sagen.Nee, ich mach
das einmal die Woche. Und wenn ich das einmal
die Woche mache, dann mache ich das nicht
ohne Auto, weil ich natürlich deutlich
mehr zu tragen habe. Und der ÖPNV
hängt auch einfach diese ganze autofreie
Geschichte nicht ab. Es ist einfach
so, die die ganzen Busse, Bahnen, das ist
alles voll. Also würdest du sagen, dass keine
deiner Autofahrten, sagen wir 10 pro
Woche ersetbar wären durch den ÖPNV?
Nein. Also da wo ich wohne nicht. Nee.
Aber wo fehlt dann das Engagement
von Menschen wie dir, dafür zu kämpfen,
-dass es Alternativen gibt?
-Aber wir kämpfen ja dafür, wir sind ja
alle eurer Meinung, dass man sagen
kann okay. Ich finde auch Carsharing ist
eine super Option. Es muss ja nicht
jeder, der in der Innenstadt wohnt, der sagt
okay, ich fahr nur einmal die Woche
zum Tennis und ja das ist 25 Kilometer
entfernt, da nehme ich mir ein Carsharing.
Und sonst fahr ich alles mit dem Fahrrad
ab oder den Rest erreiche ich zu Fuß.
Mega! Aber so ein Leben habe ich nicht.
Ich glaube ihr ja auch nicht. Und ich wohne
halt nicht direkt in der Innenstadt
und kann direkt alles zu Fuß
erledigen, das ist bei mir einfach nicht möglich.
Bleiben wir nochmal ganz kurz bei dem Thema.
Ich wollte gerade nochmal auf Thema
Innenstadt zurückkommen. Bleiben wir mal
bei Berlin. Nina, würdest du sagen,
dass auch eine autofreie Innenstadt,
auch wenn du sie dir wünscht, eigentlich nicht
wirklich realistisch ist? Also ich glaube
komplett autofrei ist es vielleicht nicht
unbedingt, weil es wird immer
Personen geben, die auf ein Auto angewiesen sind.
Es wird immer eine Feuerwehr
geben. Der Lieferverkehr, der transportiert
wahnsinnig viele Waren, der muss
natürlich auch irgendwie motorisiert stattfinden.
Aber ich glaube, eine Autoreduzierte
Innenstadt ist auf jeden Fall möglich
und ist auf jeden Fall möglich, da beim
Privatbesitz anzusetzen. Und ich glaube,
davon haben wir dann alle was. Und ich meine auch die Leute,
die Autofahren,
sind ja auch mal zu Fuß und mit dem Fahrrad
unterwegs und haben dann
auch einen Vorteil davon, wenn es mehr
Platz gibt, wenn man sich über die Straße
gehen kann. Und ich glaube einfach,
da müssen wir so ein bisschen umdenken,
dass wir wollen alle mobil sein. Und das ist
es, dass dieses ,mobil sein nicht
mit dem Auto verknüpft wird, sondern eben
schon gerade in der Innenstadt über
den ÖPNV abgedeckt werden kann.
Übers Fahrrad und die Leute auch oder jetzt
zum Beispiel Menschen, die sagen
würden, sie würden niemals beim Fahrradfahren tun
oder treffen diese Aussage jetzt
auch, weil die Verhältnisse so sind,
wie sie sind. Und weil die Straßen
zum Beispiel so unsicher sind
und sie das Verkehrsmittel nicht
nutzen wollen. Und ich glaube, wenn sie weniger
Autosfahren würden, würden zum Beispiel
auch mehr Leute, auch vielleicht ältere
Leute umsteigen. Und genau darum geht
es auch, wenn ihr jetzt auch sagt,
eure Großeltern, die müssen
Autofahren. Ich glaube, es gibt einen Punkt,
wo es auch für ganz viele sehr alte
Leute unverantwortlich ist, Auto zu fahren
und ein viel größeres
Sicherheitsrisiko. Und dann muss man denen auch Alternativen
anbieten. Genauso wie Leute unter 18,
die keinen Führerschein haben. die kann man
nicht ausschließen, die sollen auch mobil
sein. Und in der Innenstadt haben
wir kurze Wege oder eben wie in Berlin
einen sehr gut ausgebauten ÖPNV.
Und ich glaube, darauf kann man sich
verlassen und den pushen. Und ich glaube
auch, dass es halt nicht reicht,
nur Anreize zu schaffen, jetzt fahrt alle
mit dem ÖPNV, wir verdichten den Takt.
Ist das wichtig. Aber wenn es dem Auto so
bequem gemacht wird oder es so bequem
ist, ein Auto zu besitzen. Weil der Parkplatz
nichts kostet, weil man das einfach
überall hinstellen kann, weil man sich
damit bewegen kann, weil es wahnsinnig
subventioniert wird, dann sehe
ich auch nicht die Leute umsteigen.
Aber was genau müsste denn dann passieren,
an euch gelbes Feld, dass ihr sagen
würdet, ihr würdet auf euer Auto
verzichten? Jetzt mal ganz, wir können
uns ja jetzt ausdenken, was wir wollen hier
in diesem Raum. Was müsste
passieren? Gar nichts. Ich muss mal ganz kurz noch
zu dem Argument etwas sagen. Ich habe
vor einigen Jahren beschlossen,
dass ich innerhalb Deutschlands nur mit dem Auto
reise, obwohl ich alle Flüge
bezahlt bekomme von meinen Kunden.
Ich könnte jederzeit mit dem Flugzeug von A
nach B fliegen, egal wohin innerhalb Deutschlands.
Ich habe aber gesagt nein,
ich sehe es nicht ein, so viel
Luftverschmutzung oder Umweltverschmutzung
einzugehen, nur für, ich sag mal,
einen relativ kurzen Weg. Also nehme ich dafür
das Auto. Würde das Thema Autos
abschaffen, in den Innenstädten Thema
werden, dann würde ich wieder
fliegen. Und da ist halt die Frage, ob das wieder
im Sinne Aller wäre, wenn die Menschen
wieder viel mehr
-ohne
-Welcher Flughafen liegt denn in der
Innenstadt? Bitte? Welcher Flughafen
liegt denn in der Innenstadt?
Na ja, man muss ja irgendwie in die Innenstadt
kommen. Wenn ich jetzt
von München bis nach Hamburg reise,
dann kann ich das einfach mit dem Auto tun
-oder nicht.
-Oder mit der Bahn, das geht sogar
schneller. Du musst nicht
vom Flughafen irgendwo hinfahren.
Ja, aber mit der Bahn ist meistens
viel zu teuer, da zahle ich weniger Sprit.
Und da bin ich viel flexibler. Wir sind
so unflexibel hier in Deutschland,
in den deutschen Innenstädten.
Berlin ist vielleicht ein schlechtes Beispiel.
In Berlin, da fährt in jeder Straße
eine Straßenbahn. Aber Köln, Düsseldorf
und etwas kleinere Städte, da ist das nicht
der Fall. Und ich wäre voll dafür,
wenn öffentliche Verkehrsmittel
umsonst wären. Für die Leute, die zum Beispiel
in einer Stadt wohnen. Da stimme ich dir
zu die Bahn und öffentlichen Verkehr
umsonst machen oder zumindest
billiger. Wenn ihr da zustimmt, könnt
ihr tatsächlich gerne. Auf jeden
Fall, es ist super sinnvoll ÖPNV kostenlos
oder zumindest kostengünstiger zu machen,
weil aktuell eben die Leute, die sich
auch gar kein Auto leisten können, von der Mobilität
generell eher ausgeschlossen
sind. Das Problem ist bloß nur den ÖPNV
günstiger zu machen oder kostenlos.
Führt dann trotzdem nicht dazu,
dass die Leute auch vom Auto auf den ÖPNV
umsteigen. Doch dann haben wir nämlich
genau das Thema, die Leute, die gar kein
Auto fahren wollen, sondern müssen,
können da wiederum sagen: Okay, geil, es gibt
die Option vielleicht auch aus finanziellen
Gründen. Und ich denke,
da wird es viele geben, die umsteigen
würden. Die sagen würden, ich würde viel
über die Öffis nehmen. Klar, gut,
da wird ein anderes Thema. Als Frau will
ich nachts nicht mehr der Öffis
nehmen, aber es würde viel, viel mehr Leute,
gerade die, die eben nicht eigentlich
auf ihr Auto oder unbedingt auf ihr Auto
angewiesen sein wollen umsteigen. Ich gebe
die Frage auch direkt an euch weiter.
Was müsste sich denn für euch
verändern, dass sie sagen würde, ich würde komplett
auf mein Auto verzichten bzw. was für Alternativen
würdet ihr dafür brauchen?
Schreib es mal in die Kommentare.
Ich würde gerne noch mal zu dem Thema
Privilegien zurückkommen. Katja,
du setzt sich viel damit auseinander,
warum das Verkehrssystem in Deutschland
und auch grundsätzlich rassistisch
und sexistisch ist. Vielleicht
kannst du das noch mal erklären, warum ist
-das überhaupt so?
-Unter den Personen, mit denen ich für mein
Buch gesprochen habe, sind viele
gewesen, die haben gesagt, ich muss Autofahren,
ich will das gar nicht. Ich mag
noch nicht mal Autofahren. Das fängt
bei einer älteren Dame an, wo der Mann
Parkinson hat. Die war lange Zeit
Radfahrerin, muss jetzt mit 76
Autofahren, weil der Mann freiwillig verzichtet.
In Deutschland wird es ja nicht
verboten. Es gab eine Transfrau, die zweimal
zusammengeschlagen worden und an Haltestellen
und die sagt mein Auto ist
mein Safe Space, weil ihr in Deutschland
es nicht schafft, für mich eine gute
Umgebung zu schaffen. Ich will aber
nicht Autofahren. Ich will, dass ihre Idee war
zum Beispiel, dass in einem Waggon
immer Menschen mitfahren. Da kann man
Einstiegshilfe machen, da kann man
Auskunft erteilen. Das bieten wir denen
aber nicht. Rassistisch heißt ich meine,
ihr kann wahrscheinlich alle quadromilf,
Jasmina, mit 4 Kindern eine schwarze
Frau, die fährt auch Auto, obwohl sie es nicht
will. Obwohl es gegen die Zukunft
ihrer Kinder ist, weil sie als schwarze Frau
mit diesen Kindern unterwegs immer
angepöbelt wird. Und das sind Sachen,
die ins Auto treiben. Nicht, weil das Auto
toll ist als Lösung sei. Die machen so
eine Art Bypassing um gesellschaftliche
Probleme, die wir haben.
Katja, ist das dann aber
nicht ein Argument für Autos?
Nein, weil die Menschen, die nicht
Auto fahren können und wollen, die sind
weiterhin dieser Gefahr
ausgesetzt. Die bleiben teilweise an den Orten,
wo sie feiern. Es wird ja alles
Sachen, die ich erfahren habe. Und ich weiß,
dass man ganz ehrlich, auf dem Land
ist das auch ganz oft ein Problem,
dass die Leute alkoholisiert
fahren, weil es keine Alternativen gibt.
Es gibt kein Argument gegen Auto.
Also es spricht ja schon für das Auto.
Nein, es spricht nicht für das Auto in dem Moment,
wo nicht jeder Autofahren kann.
Also wir reden ja jetzt ein bisschen
aneinander vorbei, glaube ich. Ich glaube,
wir alle hier sind uns einig, dass man
alles tun muss, um Sexismus und Rassismus
aus der Öffentlichkeit zu verdrängen
und alles dagegen zu tun, damit das kein Thema
mehr ist. Ich glaube, da ist
hier keiner von uns anderer Meinung ist
und da unterstützen wir alles, was dagegen
getan werden kann. Ich glaube, was aber
wichtig ist, dass du einfach
einmal gesagt hast, es gibt unterschiedliche
Lebensrealitäten, für die man
Lösungen finden muss. Und natürlich gibt es viele
Sachen, die Geschichten, wie du
gerade erzählt hast, wo Menschen vielleicht
das Auto nutzen müssen, obwohl sie eigentlich
nicht wollen. Allensbach hat
im letzten halben Jahr– Allensbach ist
ein sehr renommiertes Umfrageinstitut –zwei
Umfragen gemacht, da kommt raus,
dass wirklich die deutliche Mehrheit
der Menschen in Deutschland sagt,
sie können ihren Alltag ohne Auto gar nicht
meistern. Schlimm genug! Also ich finde
das das Beste, was wir eigentlich machen
können, ist doch wirklich einfach
produktive Lösungen finden, zum Beispiel
mehr machen für diese ganzen– Also
du unterstellst uns gerade, dass wir keine
produktiven Lösungen haben oder?
Autos zu verbannen würde ja auch Pool-Services
und Shared-Services verbannen. Nein,
das hat niemand von uns gesagt! Also die sind
ja genauso – Das haben wir doch grade
eben gesagt, das ist Quatsch! Das hat niemand
von uns gesagt! Dafür kann man ja
auch noch vieles machen, um das zu pushen.
Raul, wer sollte denn bei der Mobilitätswende
die größte Verantwortung
übernehmen? Ist es Politik
ist es die Wirtschaft, ist es ist
-die Zivilgesellschaft?
-Danke für die Frage, weil das ist das, was
mich die ganze Zeit so aufregt gerade.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, wir leben im 21.
Jahrhundert und bisher jede
verkehrs- oder klimagünstige Innovationen
die es aus Automobilindustrie gab,
kam, weil sie gesetzlich verpflichtet wurde.
Das heißt, ich erinnere mich ich hatte
vor ein paar Jahren ein Gespräch
mit dem Klimafolgenforschung Mojib
Latif aus Kiel und ich hatte ihn gefragt haben
Sie Hoffnung? Haben Sie Hoffnung, was den Klimawandel
angeht? Und er meinte ja,
ich habe Hoffnung, weil wir sind
gesellschaftlich dazu in der Lage,
Dinge zu verändern, wenn die Notwendigkeit
da ist. Wir konnten FCKW verbieten
und es wurde prophezeit, dass die Kühlschrankindustrie
demnächst pleite
geht, wir konnten den Katalysator
verpflichtend machen in jedem Fahrzeug,
die Automobilindustrie in Deutschland
hat gesagt, danach sind wir pleite. Das haben
Sie damals gesagt in den 80er und 90er
Jahren und ein Scheiß ist passiert,
sie ist nicht pleite gewesen, im Gegenteil,
die Fahrzeuge wurden immer
größer. Und wenn wir jetzt endlich
mal verpflichten würden, gesetzlich, also
die Politik in die Verantwortung zu nehmen,
zu sagen: Wie schaffen wir es,
jetzt endlich mal die ganze
Aufmerksamkeit der Automobilindustrie zu nehmen
und sie in den ÖPNV und Alternativen
zu stecken und genauso gesetzlich reguliert
weiterzumachen, zusagen: Die Autos
dürfen nicht mehr soundsoviel Umwelt
verschmutzen, die Autos dürfen nicht
mehr so groß sein und es sollte nicht mehr
als soundsoviel Prozent Parkplätze in der Stadt
geben. Da würde sich der ganze Spaß
schon selber regulieren aber
freiwillig passiert das nicht von Seiten
der Automobilindustrie. Ganz kurz– Das ist
etwas, wo ich jetzt endlich mal zu Ende
reden möchte. Das ist etwas, wo ich mir
endlich wünschen würde, dass all
die Autofans, die Jahrzehnte ihre Partys
hatten, ja, dass sie jetzt endlich mal
auch verstehen: Wir leben im 21.
Jahrhundert, Dinge müssen wir verändern,
sonst geht es auf so vielen Ebenen
und nicht nur im Klimaschutz nicht weiter.
Sophia, du bist ein Schritt
zurückgegangen. Ihr anderen beiden seid
stehen geblieben. Also da stimme ich dir
nicht zu, dass die Automobilhersteller
immer nur innovative Sachen
erschaffen haben, wenn es erst gesetzlich geregelt
war. Es gibt zum Beispiel E-Antriebe
oder früher gab es die LPG Geschichte und so
weiter. Das gab es alles schon viel eher,
-bevor–
-Wurde aber nie gepusht ausreichend! ja
aber – wie der zum Beispiel
der "Ein-Liter-Lupo"
Vom Staat wurde es zum Beispiel
erst mal nicht subventioniert–
-Weil es auch nicht seine Aufgabe ist!
-–und es wurde auch vom Endverbraucher gar
nicht angenommen. Also ein Automobilhersteller
muss in erster Linie
erst mal gucken, wie mache ich Umsatz?
Das ist das Leben. Ein Hersteller,
ein Entwickler, wie auch immer,
der macht das nicht zur Freude aller,
sondern er muss immer erst mal
gucken, wie mache ich den meisten Umsatz?
Und wenn Automobilhersteller vor zehn
oder zwanzig Jahren ein E-Auto entwickelt hat,
was aber niemand gefördert hat, was niemand
angenommen hat, dann hat der erst
mal gar keine Macht, das irgendwie
weiter auszubauen.
Also mein Mitleid zu Volkswagen
hält sich echt in Grenzen, aber sorry.
Die deutsche Autoindustrie ist
die innovativste der Welt. Wir haben
mit Abstand die meisten
angemeldeten Patente. Und wenn wir zum Beispiel mal
konkret auf das Beispiel der E-Mobilität
gehen–finde ich ein tolles Beispiel–
weil es muss eben zum einem den Markt,
also beim Verbraucher, der muss ja
auch das Modell annehmen. Viele
Menschen denken momentan darüber nach, sich
ein E-Auto zu kaufen. Was ist das größte
oder das wichtigste Kriterium?
Eine ausreichende flächendeckende
Ladeinfrastruktur? Was haben wir nicht?
Eine ausreichende
flächendeckende Ladeinfrastruktur! Wir hängen total
hinterher. Wir selbst, also die Automobilhersteller,
wir sind Weltmeister
was E-Autos angeht. Die deutschen
Hersteller haben da wirklich den Anschluss
absolut gewonnen, sie sind
sogar in die Führungsposition gegangen.
Beim automatisierten Fahren sind
wir sogar das das Land, was als Erstes
eine Gesetzgebung hatte, damit wir auch das pushen
können. Aber es muss jetzt
-auch mal investiert werden.
-Also E-Autos lösen meiner Meinung nach vor
allem in den Innenstädten einfach
nicht das Problem. Also ich habe das Gefühl–
Darf ich kurz fragen, was ist denn
das Problem? Das Problem ist –meiner Meinung
nach hängen wir so sehr am Auto
fest, dass es jetzt eben unbedingt das E-Auto
sein soll. Und welches Problem
verursacht das Auto für dich in der Innenstadt egal
ob E-Auto oder Verbrenner? Das Auto,
egal ob E-Auto oder ein Verbrenner,nimmt
in der Innenstadt wahnsinnig viel
Platz weg, beispielsweise in Berlin– Ok,
dann bräuchten wir höhere Parkhäuser.
Dann ist das Problem schon mal erledigt.
-Aber also–
-Oder weniger Autos,
Oder weniger Autos, genau! Es gibt
viele Probleme. Es ist einerseits, das hatten
wir auch schon, dass E-Autos
nicht die Lösung aus der Klimakrise sind,
weil auch die hergestellt werden. Auch da ist
die ist die Entsorgung der Batterien
-unklar.
-Es gibt ja diverse Recycling Modelle, die
-auch immer weiterentwickelt werden.
-Das stimmt zwar, es gibt trotzdem ein
Reifenabrieb, aber es löst nicht– Ist
das für dich das einzige Problem? Es gibt
viele Probleme. Lass mich
ausreden. Also es gibt einerseits das Problem,
die Emissionen sind dadurch nicht
verschwunden. Es gibt das Problem des
Platzes. Es ist ein Wahnsinn,
dass der öffentliche Raum, zehn bis zwölf
Quadratmeter, in Berlin einfach so
genutzt werden kann vom Auto! Ich kann mein Sofa
nicht einfach auf die Straße stellen
und mich hinsetzen Da kommt das Ordnungsamt!
Was ist das denn für ein Argument?
Warum solltest du dein Sofa auf der Straße
abstellen? Naja das Auto kann man
einfach abstellen. Das ist kostenlos.
Ich meine nur es wird– Ja, aber ein Autos
ist ein Nutztgegenstand, den du brauchst
auf der Straßen und es ist auch nicht
kostenlos. Ich zahl an jeder Ecke,
an irgendeiner Parkuhr, auf jedem
Parkplatz, auf jedem Parkdeck zahlt man
Geld zum Parken. Ich weiß nicht,
wodurch man hier in Berlin kostenlos parken kann.
Es ist nicht überall so, aber es kommt
lanngsam was. Es ist hauptsächlich
kostenpflichtig. Ja, und dann kostet
es für Anwohner 20 Euro im Jahr. Das steht
aber nicht im Verhältnis dazu,
dass man in einer großen Großstadt lebt,
wo ich ansonsten irgendwie 400 Euro
für zehn Quadratmeter Zimmer zahlen muss.
Man muss sich überlegen, der öffentliche
Raum ist ein wahnsinnig wertvolles Gut
den kann man nicht voll stellen,
wenn gleichzeitig es ein Problem gibt,
dass es zu wenig Grünflächen gibt oder zu wenig
Spielplätze. Aber das könnte man
doch easy regeln, indem man jedes
neu gebaute Gebäude erst mal ordentlich
unterkelltert und eine riesengroße
Tiefgarage rein macht und viel, viel mehr
Parkdecks baut, viel höher, dass man
Autos quasi übereinander vielmehr stapeln kann.
Also du willst den Autobestand
nicht reduzieren? Bitte?
Du willst dein Autobestand nicht
reduzieren, du versuchst eher jetzt
-Lösungen-
-Naja, es geht ja gerade um den Platz. Ja!
-und das wäre ein Lösungsvorschlag
um den Platz zu schaffen.
Also ich baue
lieber Häuser als Parkhäuser.
Da sind wir eigentlich schon bei einem
kleinen Minikompromiss, deswegen lass uns
in die Kompromissrunde gehen. Es wurden
ja jetzt schon einige kleine Kompromisse
immer mal wieder in die Runde
reingeworfen, deswegen lass uns das jetzt
gerne vertiefen. Ich habe jetzt
einen Kompromissvorschlag für euch. Können
wir uns darauf einigen, dass alle
–und damit meine ich alle– ein Recht
auf eine sichere,
klimafreundliche und bezahlbare Alternative zum Auto
als Verkehrsmittel haben? Und dass deswegen der Ausbau
des öffentlichen
Nahverkehrs, der Fahrradwege
sowie Carsharing-Konzepte durch höhere
Parkgebühren finanziert werden. Könnt
euch gern einen Schritt auf mich zubewegen,
einen Schritt auf mich zu gehen,
wenn ihr mir zustimmt Schwierig!
Also ich glaube dem ersten Teil
zuzustimmen ist easy, höhere Parkgebühren
oder an sich solche Konzepte. Da muss
man dann aber auch wieder mit bedenken,
dass es sozial gerecht ist. Also es ist
mir wirklich wichtig, weil es gibt
auch Menschen, die aufs Auto
angewiesen sind. Für die sind diese höheren
Parkgebühren eben nicht
einfach leistbar. Und alle diese Lösungen
oder Transformation,
Mobilitätswende müssen so gestaltet werden,
dass sie sozial gerecht
sind und sozial aufgestellt sind.
Und bei dem Lösungsvorschlag, wenn man
noch einbaut, dass man es so macht,
dass auch die mitgenommen werden, die Unterstützung
bekommen, die sich das nicht
einfach leisten können, dann
gehe ich gerne einen Schritt nach Vorne.
Das könnte man ja machen, das können
wir gerne hinzufügen. Dann habe ich Simon
einen Schritt zu mir gewonnen. Du
auch, Alicia auch, ihr habt euch auch mich
-zubewegt, sagt er noch mal warum?
-Es braucht einfach einen Relaunch von
Mobilität. Also das Auto ist überall
da richtig, wo es auch wirklich gut genutzt
wird. Und ich glaube trotzdem, dass wir alle
auch gerade in einer überalternden
Gesellschaft irgendwann in die Situation
kommen können, dass wir nicht Auto fahren
sollten. Und das ist etwas, wo ich gerne
für die Leute eine Alternative
bereithalten würde, dass wenn sie merken,
ich kann das nicht mehr, ich will
das nicht mehr, dass sie da auch mobil
sein können.
Relaunch, Alternative: Das sind
jetzt eure Schlagwörter für die Kompromisse.
Ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne die Köpfe
zusammenstecken und euch jeweils
Kompromissvorschläge für die andere
Seite überlegen.
Also das ist ja immer das einzelne
Einzelschicksal genutzt werden, um nichts
-zu tun.
-Die haben ja auch keine andere Lösung. Die
sagen ja nicht: Okay, wir machen jetzt
autofrei weil, wir machen ABC anders Falls
ihr euch die ganze Zeit beim Gucken
dieser Diskussion gedacht habt: "Oh Mann,
wieso nennen die diesen Kompromissvorschlag
nicht? Der ist doch
total logisch, der liegt auf der Hand",
dann schreibt den gerne mal
in die Kommentare. Was du meinst
mit der Regulierung, dass das politisch
festgesetzt sein muss. Ganz ehrlich,
wir zahlen auch alle verdammt viel Geld dafür,
dass wir damit fahren dürfen wir zahlen
Steuern. Das Auto an sich. Ok, sehr gut.
Ich bin gespannt auf eure Kompromissvorschläge
und wir fangen
an mit dem gelben Feld. Was habt ihr euch
überlegt? Also wir haben uns überlegt
Autos nicht zu verbieten, aber Raum für mehr
Parkplätze zu schaffen und zwar nicht
auf den Straßen, sondern tatsächlich
entweder Ausbau im Untergrund, also mehr
Tiefgaragen oder mehr höher
stöckige Parkhäuser für Anwohner, aber
-auch Besucher von Innenstädten
-Und eben auf Innovation zu setzen. Also
das hatten wir ja schon öfter
angesprochen, vor allem Pool Services
auszuweiten, Shared Services
auszuweiten, den Menschen diese Möglichkeit zu geben,
sodass sie alle mitgenommen werden
und eben auch wirklich die ganzen Potenziale
zu nutzen, die in der Digitalisierung
liegen. Da kann man das Ganze verbessern,
das gerade der ruhende Verkehr
reduziert wird, das auch gerade auf öffentlichen
Plätzen mehr Platz geschaffen
wird. Da sind wir ja quasi auf der Seite,
das wollen wir ja auch. Und da gibt es mit vernetzten
Verkehr, mit automatisierten
Fahren– was irgendwann auch Realität
sein wird –und mit Kommunikation
unter den Fahrzeugen so viel
Potenzial, um die ganze Situation zu verbessern.
-Und das sollten wir jetzt nutzen.
-Dazu kommt natürlich der Ausbau von den
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln,
damit es einfach attraktiver gemacht wird.
Damit vielleicht wirklich ein paar
Leute vom Auto umsteigen auf die öffentlichen
Verkehrsmittel oder einfach sagen:
Okay, komm, ich fahr von A nach B, ich muss gar
nicht umsteigen, es sind nur zwei
Stationen. Ich erledige das dann noch
mit den öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln und dass das so einfach ein bisschen
interessanter wird und natürlich die Taktung
auch verkürzt wird, dass man nicht
mehr so lange Wartezeiten hat, dass man
nicht irgendwie mit 40, 50, 60 anderen
Leuten sich in einen U-Bahn Waggon
quetscht, sondern dass es einfach angenehm
-ist, damit zu fahren.
-Und was uns halt so geeint hat ist, dass
wir gesagt haben letzten Endes muss
wirklich jede Lebensrealität betrachtet
-werden, so dass jeder Mobilität hat.
-Das ist euer Kompromissvorschlag. Was sagt
ihr, grünes Feld? Würdet ihr euch auf die andere
Seite einen Schritt zu bewegen?
Also ich bin ja schon eher einen
Schritt zurück gegangen, weil ich finde es zwar
gut, vor allem den ÖPNV auszubauen,
aber gerade wenn es um die Parkflächen geht,
finde ich es genau der falsche Weg,
gerade in der Stadt. Ich meine, wenn ich mir
überlege, wir brauchen hier
Wohnraum oder Grünflächen und alles mögliche,
aber wirklich keine Parkhäuser. Also
das finde ich, es geht total in die falsche
Richtung und da würde ich mich auf jeden
Fall dagegen sperren. Katja, Raul, ist
das auch der Grund,
warum ihr stehengeblieben seid?
Mir geht es halt nicht weit genug,
weil diese Wins hätten wir alle vor 10-20
Jahren schon haben können. Das sind
jetzt alles relativ alte Erkenntnisse,
weswegen ich da bin, wo ich jetzt
bin und keinen Schritt weiter gegangen bin,
weil ich dachte: Ja
ok, die alte Binsenweisheit!
Vielleicht ändert sich das ja mit eurem
Kompromissvorschlag, den könnt ihr gern
-der anderen Seite jetzt vortragen.
-Wir haben gesagt, dass der der Staat in
die Verantwortung genommen werden
muss– ab nächstem Jahr beispielsweise– dafür
zu sorgen, dass die Automobilindustrie,
wenn er sie fördern möchte
und subventionieren will, weil alle
danach jammern, dann mindestens genauso viel Geld
investieren sollte, in Alternativen,
also in ÖPNV, und dabei berücksichtigen sollte
die Party die die Automobilindustrie
die letzten 30 Jahre hatte
und deswegen vielleicht sogar auch die Alternative
30 Jahre lang bevorzugen
-sollte.
-Und das gleichzeitig was die
Flächengerechtigkeit angeht, dem Rechnung
getragen wird, dass dort, wo es schon
Alternativen gibt– wie jetzt zum Beispiel,
vor allem in Städte –dass dort der Raum
auch aufgeteilt wird und dass dann
zum Beispiel Parkraum schrittweise reduziert
wird und der Raum beispielsweise in einer Buslinie
oder dem Radverkehr zugesprochen
-wird.
-Und ich darf in Österreich beraten, die
Klimaschutz Ministerin die macht so,
dass sie immer aus 1,5 Grad Ziel guckt.
Sie will Österreich zu einem
bestimmten Punkt klimaneutral haben und sie schaut
drauf: Was macht diese Maßnahmen, die sie umsetzen?
Erreichen wir damit das Ziel
eher oder fallen wir sogar noch
zurück? Also so was wie Bonus-Malus-System
und das will ich in Deutschland
auch gern haben.
Das ist aber kein Kompromiss, das ist
nur eure Meinung, die er weiterhin vertritt.
Kompromiss wäre ja jetzt auf uns
zuzugehen, um das zum Beispiel nicht alle
Autos abgeschafft werden müssen. Was wäre,
wenn wir– Wir fordern nicht, dass alle
Autos abgeschafft werden müssen,
sondern dass –ihr kriegt ja weiterhin auch Geld,
aber die anderen
Systeme kriegen auch Geld.
Ich glaube das Problem bei dem Kompromissvorschlag
ist, Raul,
dass was bei dir in der Äußerung,
was ich eigentlich schade finde ist,
dass dieses Feindbild aufgebürdet wird:
der Autofahrer, die Party, der Autofahrer,
die Party der Automobilindustrie,
das sind so diese alten Rollenbilder. Also
ich glaube, wenn man Zukunft denken
will und Zukunft machen will, dann hilft
es nicht zu gucken, was in der Vergangenheit
schief gelaufen ist
oder welche alten Vorurteile man
noch gegen gewisse Gruppen hat, sondern man
muss sich halt wirklich dem hier und Jetzt
stellen und dialogbereit sein und gucken,
wie kann man einander
irgendwie verstehen und Lösungen finden.
Also ich glaube wir kommen nur dann
weiter, wenn wir alle gemeinsam,
auch die bisher Geförderten,
einfach mal reflektieren, was für Privilegien
sie in den letzten Jahrzehnten
eigentlich genossen haben: von Abwrackprämie bis hin
zu einfach kostenlos liefern von Straßen.
Dass wir dann eben auch dafür genauso
kämpfen müssen, dass es günstige
Alternativen gibt, dass es den Ausbau
der Deutschen Bahn gibt, dass ist
die Weiterentwicklung von ÖPNV ist,
dass es weniger Parkplätze und mehr
Raum für Kinder und Familien in Großstädten
-gibt.
-Wir haben uns jetzt eure Seite auch mal
angehört. Ihr habt euch unsere Seite
angehört und wir haben halt auch einen
ganz guten Vorschlag eigentlich
gemacht, der ja irgendwie bei euch auf Metall
getroffen ist. Und vielleicht denkt ihr ja
auch noch mal ein bisschen drüber nach,
also beide Seiten einfach mal! Ihr habt
ihr eure Punkte bereits genannt, ihr habt
eure Punkte genannt und ihr kommt
nicht zusammen und das ist komplett okay,
weil dafür ist in diesem Format
auch Raum. Trotzdem habt ihr genügend
Kompromissvorschläge und Argumente
bereits ausgetauscht. Ich glaube, so
wie ihr gerade steht, das macht ja
auch deutlich, wie schwierig diese Debatte ist
und wie viel häufiger wir vielleicht
auch noch in diesem Format und grundsätzlich
in der Gesellschaft darüber
diskutieren müssen. Deswegen danke ich euch,
dass ihr euch zumindest
soweit bewegt habt. Und ja, vielen
Dank für die Diskussion! Ja, ich habe
hier zum Beginn der Folge noch komplett
überambitioniert gesagt, dass ich sehr optimistisch
bin, dass wir heute den einen
oder anderen Kompromiss finden werden.
Und seien wir mal ehrlich, wir haben keinen
wirklichen Kompromiss gefunden.
Niemand war am Ende im Kompromissfeld und das ist
auch komplett okay. Hat mich aber
trotzdem überrascht, weil ich noch mal gemerkt
habe, wie emotional diese eigentlich
ziemlich technische Debatte über Mobilität
am Ende dann doch ist. Und das zeigt
ja nur, dass sie uns alle betrifft.
Wenn ihr mehr von diesen Debatten
sehen wollt, hier auf diesem Kanal, dann folgt
dem sehr gerne, könnte hier machen.
Hier oben findet ihr ein weiteres Video von 13
Fragen und hier unten ein weiteres Video
zum Thema.